so here's an interesting multi-part
question that comes under complex
numbers
particularly graphs and inequalities
with complex numbers now because there
are multiple parts to this question
to understand the later parts you really
need to have the earlier parts so we're
just going to tackle the whole thing
from the beginning the question starts
the variable complex number
zed satisfies and then there's this
equation here
um the absolute value or the modulus of
z minus 2 minus i
equals 1. we'll come back to what that
means in a second
use a diagram to find the maximum and
minimum values of the modulus
of z okay so before we start to even
answer the question we need to know
what on earth this is even saying
because that's kind of the foundation
and then the question that we get asked
is based on the the foundation that we
build here
okay so in order to understand what this
means you've really got to have
a deep sort of understanding of modulus
and absolute value
and not just be able to sort of crunch
the numbers but actually also interpret
what they mean
so let's think about a really simple
example let's go back to real numbers
before we
get too deep into the complex numbers
here if i ask you
what's the absolute value of 3 take away
8. hopefully you're familiar enough with
absolute values and just arithmetic now
that you could say oh without too much
thought that's the absolute value of
negative 5
and that's 5. and you would be correct
however you know this is an arithmetic
way of looking at things and you can see
that
the question itself even if you didn't
know anything else it tells you to use a
diagram and there's this language like
triangle inequality so actually a more
useful way to think about
absolute value and modulus in the
context of this question
will be visually we'll be geometrically
rather than just thinking about the
arithmetic
so what does the absolute value of three
minus eight
mean in geometric terms well it's really
about distance
you know this idea of the modulus we
connect it to distance in complex
numbers
but it's also connected to distance with
real numbers uh what this means is
what's the distance from three to eight
or from eight to three it doesn't matter
which way you go
which is why you can just switch the
order in there and the absolute value
doesn't matter
so to illustrate this right you think
about what 3 and 8 look like on a number
line
if i position 0 there 3 there i guess
that would make 6 about here so then 8
will be a little further along
okay the distance from three to eight of
course
is going to be this spot here and if we
think about trying to traverse that
distance the way that you find it is
you could do just eight take away three
but that's the same as
three take away 8 and then take the
absolute value that distance
5 is what the absolute value function
gives us
so if that's the way it works in real
numbers how does it work in complex
numbers
well if i say to you what's the absolute
value of z
take away w in the same way
that this is the the distance between
three and eight
this is the difference between z and w
it's just that now we're thinking
in two dimensions if you go back to this
idea
you know very fundamentally of the
modulus the modulus of
z we really have just a special case of
the absolute value it's the absolute
value of z
take away zero in other words the
difference between or the distance
between i should say
z and the origin which is what we define
the modulus to be
so what we're saying here in this
particular case
is we've got a particular value of w
being let's have a look here this is
going to be 2 plus i
pc that if i substitute 2 plus i into
this
line above what am i going to get i'll
get the absolute value of z
take away 2 plus i when you expand
the brackets in here you're going to get
z take away 2
take away i so what we're saying is the
distance
from z to this point here 2 plus i
should always equal 1. what is that
it's a set of points z it's a variable
complex number z right and we know every
complex number is represented by a point
on the complex plane and all of those
points share this property that their
distance
from two plus i is going to equal one
what's the name of the set of points
that are all
an equal distance from a central point
and of course we know this is
a circle so that's why you're going to
get
uh whoops that was a partial delay which
i didn't want to do
this diagram here let's move this up so
it's a bit closer to where we're doing
our
working here we go so here's one i
prepared earlier just so that i could do
it more neatly and quickly
for you here is the circle we might say
the the locus to use a very fancy word
the collection of points that the set of
points on the complex pane
that are all exactly one unit from this
central point uh w which i've designated
as two plus i
so you can see this is the radius here
of one and that's why if you think about
this the coordinates of this
in cartesian terms would be two comma
one and so since you're
one unit raised above the x axis that's
why if you go down
for a radius of one you you just touch
the axis your tangent actually to the
real axis there
okay so now that i have you go back to
the question a diagram that represents
all those complex numbers z they all sit
on the circumference
of this circle i can now answer the
actual question they're asking
use a diagram to find the maximum and
minimum values
of the modulus is it the maximum minimum
values
of the modulus of z now what this means
is you know if i
take any point and i'm just going to
i'll pick one right let's let's call
here's a point over here the modulus of
z of course is going to be the distance
from
uh that point right there to the origin
so it would be that distance
there so i could find a different value
for the modulus z if i picked a
different point so here's another point
over here
and you can see even on my rough drawing
that's going to be a little bit further
away
than the first point that i chose so
clearly the modulus is it is variable
and there is a point which is the lowest
value for modulus of z and there's a
point where it's the
highest now what you can hopefully see
if i get rid of those ones there
and maybe i'll move this sort of up here
out of the way
what you can hopefully see is that
let's put this guy in there where you're
going to get these
biggest and smallest values of the
modulus of z are going to be on the
extreme points
of the circle in relation to the origin
so if i draw
from the origin an interval that goes
all the way
through the center of the circle you can
see that this spot here is going to be
the closest
right it's sort of like a you can
imagine a perpendicular line a normal
actually is the for
the word that we would use and that's
going to give you your closest distance
and then this one over here on the
opposite side of the circle
going all the way the diameter across
that's going to be my furthest
spot so just so that i can talk about
these in a little more detail let's just
give these some names
so i'm going to call this this close one
here let's call that one
z1 and then i'll call this further point
over here
z2 all right so how do i find
each of these well even though i've
never numbered them z1 and z2 i think it
might be easier to see
how to find z2 first how do we find that
modulus
well the absolute value sorry have i
chosen right one there we go
the absolute value or the modulus of z2
it's comprised of two different pieces
um you've got to get from the origin all
the way to
w we can calculate that in a second and
then we've got to get from w
all the way to z2 but that there i'll
highlight it in here
that is the radius and we already know
back from oh i've got it written here
back from the original equation provided
to us that that radius is 1.
so if that's one then all i need to do
is work out the modulus of
w let's write it in
the modulus of w and then add one to it
and i'll have
my distance now thankfully the modulus
of w i mean we can just use our
algebraic
definition you know it's going to be the
square root of x squared plus
y squared where x and y are going to be
our real and our imaginary coefficients
here
but because it's just two and one maybe
you can recognize that once you put two
in here
and one in here you're gonna get a very
easy number this is
square root of five plus 1.
so that is the modulus of z2 the
furthest
place that z can go to on the
circumference of the circle so there's
my maximum value
for the absolute value z to work out the
minimum value i just have to go in the
opposite direction
it is still related to this modulus of w
which we already know is root five but
instead of going past it
one unit the radius i have to go
backwards so it's not
the square root of five plus one it's
going to be let's write it down
the modulus of z1 will be the square
root of 5
minus 1 because it's in the opposite
direction so now
i have used my diagram i've interpreted
what's going on and i can say a maximum
value
and a minimum value for the modulus of z
i can say therefore
here comes the minimum square root of 5
minus 1
is less than or equal to the modulus of
z
which is less than or equal to square
root of 5 plus 1 that was the maximum
that i determined up here okay